you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game all right let's try d4
all right and see what black goes with
here g6e 6 g 6 so big moment grünfeld
yeah let's try this line Bishop g5 and
I'm gonna take and play Queen to d2 I'm
doing this to watch out for Queen a5
stuff and I'll saw Bishop h6 was an idea
but they're interfering with that um I'm
gonna stand this dog and I'll keep this
pawn pinned for a bit and probably just
e3 I can't do without that and this
night might turn into a king side piece
yeah let's start with this they have to
reinforce d4 where's Brooke 2 d1 night
before there's a night here I can also
look at d5 and then Knight c3 in order
to complete development in fact they
have to do that on Bishop g4 I have a
ch3 so let's see what Karen 84 comes up
with our a to capture I think I want to
go with the night just so I could get my
Bishop out
enough support for it physicians
starting to open up as well so should be
looking to get developed fast for sure
well where else is my bishop gonna go
all right let's put him there now on
Bishop g4 I think I'm gonna take should
I invest the move h3 hmm I'm gonna do
that in reason that it's useful for a
flight square and also a preventative
against some light square bishop
exchange and Knight d3 idea both of us
have good nights I like that my night
cannot be chased away for as long as
he's here take some work
so now rook c1 I think I like rook c1
not be three because I have a majority
here so I think I'm I want to set that
in motion that seems a little bit odd
they aren't a pin so this Queen can't
feel so comfortable yeah and my Knights
doing a good job of watching out of the
the Bishop Rose I am liking that h3
decision pretty level on the clock let's
see I could look at c5 this is pretty
natural but I think I want it and get
rollin with the C pawn I'm wrecked to DA
though I have to be a little bit careful
of this but now they still have to work
out of a pin I just push forward and b4
let's give this a go the night is still
pinned the Queen could move because the
bishops there to defend this guy space
invader pawn but my bishop is watching
over the squares of controls definitely
don't want to go too far away this night
will certainly drop a hammer on the
position so this should be seven is
sensible it does give up the f5 square
well that's actually
let's do this because yeah there's some
sensitive points here in the pen
Bishop can't go too far I can't go back
I'm gonna be grabbing the dark square
Bishop so I could enter a good versus
bad Bishop situation and not so healthy
six no five versus four so let's find a
good spot for my queen probably see ii
don't want to go here an idol drop into
f3 with check otherwise that would be
something to consider because on a
knight move i could just deliver mate so
let's see how they they could they could
soon be in a crossfire here threat takes
takes queen cease c3 alright they're
just forcing my hand here do I have
anything better than to take the bishop
probably not so we could have a case of
triple pawns I'm just deciding on which
of these two which one's better let's go
forward yeah tripled pawns incoming huh
well he's pinned still
maybe best you just can test the d-file
I could take that night whenever I want
let's go here first no rush
still level on the clock could follow up
with this kind of stuff pressure here
healthy three versus two and Bishop
comparison and these are the things that
I see are tipping in my favor
nothing nothing beyond that I have a
flight square okay so now I'm much
closer to taking this night out you
can't really contest the D file so now
this is allowing me to get a connected
pass pawn I don't want to take I also
don't want to get down on time let's
push fish of d5 I guess is otherwise
rook d6 is a killer and a half killer
and a half yeah let's just go here so
how am I going to open up this position
because this is a bishop is really
locking down well you know I think I
want to maintain this pin for a while
you know if I take Queen takes let's
just go here and try maybe some kind of
maneuver to dislodge the bishop see now
because I have this connected passed
pawn I could I can say that what can I
say yeah I can say that I'm winning a
King and pawn ending so yeah if we trade
everything down I think we'll be good
shape the skeleton is left on structure
alone so now I can take that night out
because if the Queen takes this rook is
unprotected and in the end I'll have
this so they're walking right into this
little tactic taking advantage of the
unprotected rook so now once I don't
want to take and straighten out the pawn
structure I probably could and still be
winning but I think um Morse yeah they
just resigned I was looking more so at
like a bishop backing up and then uh an
e4 move to dislodge the bishop and then
enter and start hitting everything okay
let's um go through it without the
engine first yeah it's uh I've I've
played around with this move and blitz a
handful of times this Bishop g5 move and
it's it's true this guy's gonna come
under some fire but widel be there and
you know to to give it enough support
with the moves that I played here Queen
d2 riff d1 nighty - you know I wonder if
maybe black could have holt
held off here on the capture because you
know right around this point when they
capture that I'm able to recapture and
it's a lot more smooth for me to
complete my development so I think maybe
black was better off castling here and
basically doing what maintaining the
tension for one more move because what
productive move do I have at this moment
I really want to complete my development
I really want to bring my Bishop out but
how do I do that so I would have to make
a decision at this moment to basically
either capture or push and I think
during the game at least I was leaning
more towards push but maybe even
captures a is a move as well yeah
maybe maybe black does not have an easy
time tracking that pond down maybe that
was some of blacks fear right around
this point instead of the castle's to
just shop away but uh hmm yeah I wonder
what what this story would be if if
black castles hmm takes and Queen c7 hmm
I don't know yeah maybe maybe it's maybe
it's upon that I can actually hang out -
hmm maybe that's the reason why I black
just went ahead and captured normally
you're right around this point you would
be as black you'd like to let's say keep
the tension and not helped me to develop
here but yeah maybe maybe I am able to
get away with just taking here what
we'll double check with the engine but
from here it was just a looking to
control stuff control the night
basically controlling the bishop and
yeah it's really coming down to a three
versus two this is the long-term
positive for white and you know it
pretty much got tricky here getting
caught in a crossfire we'll see what the
computer suggests cuz I'm pretty sure
I'm just better here especially with the
night landing in here and I have very
good control so I don't know I'm a bit
baffled as to what black can do as an
improvement it's somewhere around here
for sure right out of the opening I
think c5 was fine and knight c6 was fine
takes takes maybe maybe by maybe this
isn't a good idea maybe better is to
capture and force something like this
and then and then maybe these type of
moves are around the corner they he
bishop pair
type of position both of us two minor
pieces each Knights exchanged I guess
this is the other the other option
because I didn't really have this night
didn't really bother me so much that I
had him under control maybe maybe here
this was a moment to get in Bishop g4
and I said I would be capturing here
because if I go with castles there's
this and then the night I have to work
around this piece so maybe maybe even
here instead of castles this is another
idea I was planning to take at least
lure the night away from the d3 square
because I couldn't have well I wouldn't
be able to avoid the light square Bishop
exchange at this point so I had prepared
two to capture and then I guess if I
really wanted to stop the knight from
getting to d3
I could play Bishop g3 I don't know I
like the structure though do we have to
dial it back even further I know that
this is a move but uh yeah I guess black
has to be extra careful they have to be
timely because they are in the end what
working with double D pawns and I don't
know let's have a look at it with the
with the engine and see what kind of
suggestions I should have probably
clicked down that much sooner but uh
let's see what it has to say working
working backwards here I haven't really
played around with this one there's this
little features just out of outside of
the recording window but there's a
little just to the right of my mouse
here there's a little target if you
click on it it shows uh
it's a show threat button so it just
went off that's weird oh it's it's if
you're curious about a certain position
you could show threat so
I guess I guess like if I'm to click it
right now this show threaten and it's
gonna highlight that's the threat with
the red arrow anyhow let's see what the
graph is saying okay so let's kind of
fast-forward to this point that's where
there's some some change after 9 to c6
let's put on the the arrows as well okay
it suggests a capture it's fine with
blocks position night recapture uh-huh
so it does want to go with the night
takes was there must be a change then
with night here yeah mm-hmm I didn't
play Knight to b5 in the game but even
so even so it really just does not like
this idea of 95 hmm and from there after
that night decision to go to e5 it's
it's team white who is 4 choice hmm
let's let's carry this out then Knight
takes Knight pawn takes Bishop g4 Bishop
e2 light square bishop SAR off oh very
direct reply they're really going pawn
hunting huh - D - g5 back f5 mm-hmm you
see with in a more complex position in a
position where there are still more
pieces out and about Knight another pair
of bishops the lights where bishops on
board these ideas orbit
you know you as black you would tend to
be a bit more hesitant to play that
because of the gaps you're leaving the
light square weaknesses the dark square
weaknesses
but with fewer pieces on the board this
is me it's may be seen a bit more as a
positive than a negative for black so
it's interesting sequence to get to get
some more trades in and then and get
this majority it's it's an unhealthy
maturity but to at least get it rolling
and there is some temple ideas that
we're seeing with g5 now why they go
with that five here what's wrong with
going for our pollen grab I guess this
is an option as well but uh yeah I guess
it's it's turning out we're after Knight
to e5 it's black who's in some mmm rough
shape I guess you know 95 I should be
playing Knight to b5 look eyeing up the
c7 square hmm then consider that at all
I just focused on development and well
with my next move I was the h3 move I
was focused on avoiding the light square
Bishop exchange but uh yeah I guess I
guess what black has to do here is take
the knight not too much more to say the
decision to go to e5 really cause black
some problems I was able to keep control
and yeah I could get my majority rolling
it likes before and I guess Knight to f5
is basically a game winner
+2 here on out something close to that
it's tough to get out of the spin you
know that I don't think there's a good
way to to work around it maybe I could
have done something better right around
here instead of rook to d2 and this I
wants to push with this idea yeah and
then I'd have a these two guys but I
felt right around this point I didn't
need to change the structure at all I
could still improve somewhat and reroute
my bishop flying within the structure
the
yeah if play was to continue from here
mmm I don't know I was pointing out this
and they could push yeah maybe that
wouldn't wouldn't have been best could
do this and be fine if the pawns are
doubled here has I still have this he's
he's not worth just upon connected
passed pawn if we have this just to show
this is a game winner my King gets to
enter over here and he has to be tied
down to the c6 square just to watch over
that guy so yeah okay well it's a
basically the Knight to e5 is what's
coming down to Knight takes Knight at
this point is an important can't go with
the Knight to e5 here all right
well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
and I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you